just sitting on my desk at home when I
stabbed myself with a pencil in my eye
I was in the first grade and I was six
years old second grade probably the
third grade third grade or fourth grade
I was in seventh grade and this is the
first time I have I've told this story
because it just doesn't come up that
often my friend and I had been messing
around a little bit and I had elbowed
him in the leg so we were sitting in the
woodshop with a very attentive teacher
and as soon as he turned around my buddy
took his mechanical pencil and just kind
of gave me a quick jab in the in the
thigh
so I was walking to one of my classes in
our school there was brick wall
everywhere and I had my pencil in my
hand I was dragging it along the brick
wall and I got wedged in between a brick
and then the pencil went right into
[Music]
I was sitting at the kitchen table and I
was coloring and I like to take a
regular pencil first and I was erasing
and it jabbed right and it got lodged
right in there and I started to scream
because it hurts really really really
bad when you get anything in between
your fingers I thought I was gonna get
lead poisoning because I didn't
understand that it's not poisonous my
younger brother and I were farting
around in the living room and I don't
know why but he had sharpened a pencil
tossed it willy-nilly onto the floor and
I'm running around without my shoes on
step on it crack I did it stuck into the
bottom of my left foot and I tried to
get it out the more I tried to dig it
out the further it seemed to in mesh
itself with my flesh I was just sitting
on my desk at home and I must've just
erasing something really vigorously
gesturing a little bit too hard and it
went straight into my eye
and just immediately started freaking
out cuz I could see the mark that they
left in my eye and I was like oh my god
am I gonna go blind people have totally
noticed it without me like sharing the
information because it's like a minute
in the center of my right hand there is
a black dot it's it's it's buried under
my skin now it's just a part of me I'm
kind of a cyborg in that sense it's
actually funny because like I'm the type
of person that has never broken any sort
of bone so now that I think of it this
is probably like the worst battle scar I
honestly have is just this thing in my
eye from stabbing myself with a pencil
I just hope somebody out there can hear
my story and feel better about their
pencil stabbing so for anyone who thinks
that they're alone in this world with
their pencil scars or not there are a
lot of us out there and
if you ever feel lonely you can probably
find support on an internet forum I'm
sure there they exist you should wear it
proudly and just show that you know you
can move on from this all right you know
just find me on Twitter and I'll uh I'll
commiserate
[Music]
you